amber on twitter
asks i just spent 1 000 on a new phone
i have not bought the extended warranty
yet
but i have 60 days to decide should i
buy the two-year
extended warranty for 200
a 200 warranty on a thousand dollar
phone
oh this is a classic okay amber here's
the deal
100 percent of the time
i do not buy extended warranties
in other words never buy
an extended warranty
let's walk through this for a second
the extended warranty number one
most products have a decent warranty on
them these days anyway
number two your thousand dollar phone is
going to be replaced
fairly soon anyway
you're going to get a new phone think
about how many times you've gotten the
new phone i i wish i had a whole lineup
of all the phones i've owned in my life
from the one that used to be attached to
my car to the brick phone
all the way up to the tiny little phone
and now
the classic smartphone or so it says it
is
you're going to get another phone you're
not going to keep this phone that long
anyway
and that's true of most electronics in
the 50s and 60s electronics and
appliances
we fixed them we didn't replace them now
we throw them away
and we get a new one when your tv goes
out very seldom do you fix it
you just get another one and that's just
part of the rhythm because the
electronics are so stinking inexpensive
compared to the repairs so let's talk
about extended warranties now the math
works
if you open an extended warranty company
and you're going to sell an extended
warranty to amber for 200
i think it would be fair to assume that
the extended warranty company
opened to make a profit
they want to make a profit on that so
what is the cost
of issuing an extended warranty
the statistical probability of the
breakdown
and so you can take a thousand or ten
thousand phones just like yours amber
if you're an extended warranty company
and do an analysis
that says on average
x number of these 10 000 phones are
going to break down and on average
why it's going to cost us y or z to fix
them
in the coverage of the extended warranty
the actual repair and probability of the
repair statistically
on an extended warranty is 12 and a half
percent of the cost of the extended
warranty
the other 87 and a half percent
of the cost of the extended warranty
9 out of 10 180 out of your 200
is profit commissions
and overhead to operate the company
the actual insurance that you bought
was only twenty dollars
roughly that's what it actually
cost them to insure your phone the other
180
was called amber getting screwed
that's what that was and so
you are much better off to self-insure
through your electronics breaking down
meaning you have an emergency fund so my
little smartphone
does not have an extended warranty my
televisions
my cars my nothing
has an extended warranty i don't buy
them
because they are eighty seven and a half
percent
profit commissions marketing and
overhead
and only 12 and a half percent actual
insurance
that's the national average now it
varies a little bit from industry to
industry
electronic to electronic but that's
roughly your numbers
the point being it's a highly profitable
business for
them and so if you self-insure
on average put the 200 in your pocket
and on
average you have to do the 20 repair you
come out ahead 180 bucks on average
now you probably won't have a 20 repair
to a cell phone
but the point is mathematically you'll
always come out ahead
so there's big electronic stores huge
electronic stores full of televisions
and computers and phones and cameras and
appliances and they have really good
prices
even their the name of their store is
best buy
i mean they have really good prices
they don't make a lot of money on the
sale of a television there
their margins on those are fairly slim
they make all of their money in those
stores on
two things selling you a credit card for
the store or a finance package for your
tv
in other words on financing they make
their money and
on ready for this extended warranties
that's why when you check out buying a
number two pencil
they will try to sell you an extended
warranty
at these stores are you sure you don't
want the extended warranty
and they look at you like you've lost
your ever loving mind if you don't no my
pencil does not need a warranty thank
you
you know no i if you cannot afford to
fix the item or throw it away you
shouldn't be buying it
don't buy extended
warranties use your emergency fund to
replace or repair
and put the difference in your pocket
you're going to come out way ahead
extended warranties are a complete
mathematical
rip-off gosh i hope i wasn't unclear
don't buy extended warranties
period
period i know it seems tempting
it feels good for someone else to pay
for it but someone else isn't paying for
it
you are don't buy
extended warranties it's all about
profit for them